let's hear it up 14 6 all right makai is
a failing student he gets in trouble for
running around the room talking out of
turn falling asleep but Makai has low
self-esteem and he thinks he's bad so hi
everyone we are flux and fusion and we
decided to look at why students don't
have as much fun as they go through your
school so we find that you'll notice as
once we get past 5 meters don't play
anymore and we wanted to resolve this by
having a dedicated time in our education
system for play specifically and through
this we hope to increase engagement over
time we're going to do this by what we
call the play lab which is a modular
shared space for everyone in the school
system administrators teachers students
to come together as collaborators and
exploring new concepts so plenty can
mean many things to different people
it's it might not just be sports and
recess plays singing please freedom
please debate plays exploring the play
Lab offers a solution it will increase
creative engagement and curiosity it
will support organic experimentation and
provide a safe adaptable environment for
all teachers and students to play and
the play Lab offers teachers and
students time and space to work
collaboratively across the curriculum
this space is could be a cart or a
classroom whatever kind of space you
have available it's very adaptable it
costs nothing to whatever you want to
spend for it and the materials can be
donated by the community
parents from businesses and everybody in
the community is welcome to be involved
for mentoring ship and coming in and
visiting and leading lessons the whole
community is part of this project for
each school to play lab thank you you're
stating that everyone learns including
an administration how do they learn they
learn together teachers and
administrators can go into play lab and
actually do the things we want the kids
to do and so that they're able to sell
it to the teachers parents the school
board everyone so the teeth the
administrators are involved just as much
as the kids are they say well that we
did all the time they don't have time
well think I have they're gonna make
time yeah we're gonna make time when you
guys this is important part it's going
to be during the school day so there
will be classes that will incorporate a
lab section that can come here the
teachers will be there administrators
you know they're gonna need to interact
with the students anyway this is one way
for them to really get to know the
students that they are that are going to
be in their school I think I can ask the
question a different way teachers are
already pressed for time there's not
enough time in the school day they have
to teach to the test how are you going
to get them to take extra time to do
play administrators cause if the
ministrations are going to value that if
they spend time coming creative and
learning how to engage in the play type
it's going to transform over into better
testing and the play time is tied into
the curriculum as much as the teacher or
administrator wants it to be so they it
can be very creative in that aspect and
I'm a school administrator so one thing
that I play I play in the kindergarten I
go to kindergarten because there always
active i sit down i play with them i
spend that time learning my kids and so
this will give administrators time to
learn their kids better and they can
surf the kids much better how are you
going to prove
equity in communities communities that
are better resources having more access
to such things this can be minimal can
be tiny just it could be recycling
materials as part of the materials it
doesn't have to be a bigger than ideal
that's something emco he campaign I
concept a cart like a toolkit what is it
just go ahead yeah it's a toolkit it's a
toolkit that it can be as simple as a
tool kit it can be as simple as a cart
or it could be a whole classroom
whatever this community has the
resources to offer it's the time to play